okay he's dead anyone know what we do
next anybody Rose I have no idea anyone
else we bury him wrong and check for an
organ donor card if he has one we only
have minutes to harvest he has no wallet
I checked he is an organ donor he is
yeah give me some ice in a styrofoam
bucket here we go
we search for the organs where's the
heart
it's hard I'm not feeling well I need to
sit off
are you okay
oh my God
can you tell me why you had to cut the
face off the dummy
I didn't think it was very realistic in
the movie and it turns out it's pretty
realistic
staring at this board for days
I'm so close to putting it together
there's got to be something we missed
let's go over this again the video shows
that the pie came from a high angle
so it would have hit your face
like this
mm-hmm
Don't Close Your Eyes
no no it actually was from up higher
is that about right yeah good clean
yourself up let's do this again all
right let's go to the video again
sweet kick lastly exits the building and
then you get hit
what else do we know we know that Leslie
was about 15 feet in front of you
so clearly the assailant has terrible
aim
or
Leslie wasn't the target
well who then
okay that's permanent marker go find Ben
get a list of everyone he's ever fired
go go
Hey Jake can I show you something over
here sure thing about trying to send
Genevieve a sexy pic just move my bubble
butt pop nope I'm out
who's that I don't know
um excuse me pal take care of my desk
don't be a dumb dumb squad meet
detective Adrian pimento he's been deep
undercover for the last 12 years but
he's just resurfaced and he's rejoining
the nine nine that is
some
you've reached the voicemail of Dwight
Kirch root please leave
[Music]
I have no feeling in my fingers or penis
but I think it was worth it
um I was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept throwing
him until he exhausted himself and uh
then
how about icing it LOL it's white
God I hate this
Leslie wait here
at Macklin is on the case
no don't worry
I can do this
believe in me
that's broken
hold on real quick uh spell your last
name for me got it got it nice also got
this dude's briefcases just laying there
kind of a panic move
I believed in you but you should put
that back okay
questions what'd you do undercover I
worked for Jimmy The Butcher figures
that is an A-list mobster tell me
literally everything everyone shut up
pretty much just a Bag Man for him I
mean I did some other stuff
um we usually try to tell funnier little
stories well there's nothing funny about
what I did for the butcher I've had to
learn not to Blink because every time I
close my eyes I see a fresh Horror oh
dark but how do you keep your eyes moist
no actually I have a very funny story
about keeping my eyes moist
nope still not getting that Vibe man
really I'll get there that's my bad
everybody
are you excited
yeah
very excited
yes I'm very excited extremely excited
just very that's cool
I have spent a year here and I have to
commit or get out so
Dwight's the top salesman in the company
and he's taking me on my first sales
call today
and um I'm excited
I am very excited Ryan hasn't made a
sale yet but more importantly he hasn't
made an ally yet
is he going to be a slacker a loser wise
ass like Jim was
or is he going to join the Dwight Army
of Champions
then does it make sense to kind of lead
the conversation
you know just till it gets to a point
where where they are asking questions
so where's the sales office
when you are ready to see the sales
office the sales office will present
itself to you
your Journey Begins now
Andy and I are going to take a walk and
it's going to be just you bakitis and
these pliers
look I'm not going to torture this kid
nobody said torture
why don't you let me take a run at him
boss
in order to think like one of these guys
you have to think like them
yeah he's never seen you before so imply
that you're someone very important and
that you can make his life hell
Greg pochitis
would you like some boiling hot coffee
your face
Burt Macklin I'm with the FBI
looks like Andy's wearing him down I'm
gonna go finish him off
that is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard once you just shut up for a second
what's going on he's a jerk he is being
such a jerk it's an awful thing to say
to a human being are you crying no am I
not crying okay I'm allergic to jerks
Andy out fine I don't even care it's
stupid
Greg
um
hi I'm Leslie Knope this is Officer
Sanderson Burt Macklin FBI what the hell
do you think you're doing you can't just
hold a 16 year old kid against his will
well we were trying to question him
about this vandalism do you have any
evidence yes
two words Peach Pit
Peach Pit his DNA is all over it I
assume we don't know that we can get it
tested and if it matches your DNA then
you're going away for a long time is
this a joke
no I'm calling your shift Commander
Monday morning I am calling your boss I
don't know who to call about you the
president of the United States of
America fine
hey partner no I've been waiting for you
sorry if I surprised you it's just when
I was Undercover the middle of the night
was the only time I could do actual
police work uh how did you get in the
apartment oh it was easy I just seduced
the old lady upstairs came down the fire
escape Jimmy the window open Bing Bang
Boom I'm inside your living quarters
totally
of course next time you could just give
me a call you know two ways to pop in on
a friend I didn't kill the old lady
upstairs if that's what you're worried
about
play
oh wait a minute you think I'm being
weird
oh I shouldn't have come here this is
your apartment I'm so sorry Jake
stupid Paul stupid you get it bro hey
pimento who's Paul whoa
Paul's need was my undercover name okay
damn it Jake I don't know who I am
anymore you could have chose any name to
go undercover and you picked Paul Snead
it seems kind of crazy this was a
mistake I'm not ready I knew I wasn't
ready to go back to being police the
only job I've ever had except for a bag
of groceries at the supermarket at the
corner of Atlantic and Clinton
I guess I could go back to that again
paper or plastic yeah still got it
hey guys guess who's back
oh God no need to thank me I'm not a
hero
I am a mere defender of the office
do you know who's a real hero hero from
Heroes
that's a hero